ابتلاء اسرائيليون واصيب 14 اخرون بجروح
جراء تفجيرين داخل محطتين متقاربتين
للحافلات في القدس الغربيه
ووصفت حاله ثلاثه من الجرحى بالحرجه ووقع
تفجير الاول داخل محطه للحافلات في القدس
الغربيه اعقبه تفجير ثان قرب محطه اخرى
عند مدخل الحي الاستيطانيه رموت شمال غربي
القدس وقالت الشرطه الاسرائيليه ان شخصا
على دراجه كهربائيه وضع المتفجرات داخل
حقيبه تم تفعيلها عن بعد
الاسرائيليه الشارع الرئيسي عند المدخل
الغربي للقدس ودفعت بتعزيزات واسعه بينما
امر المفتش العام للشرطه بتفتيشه كافه
الحافلات ومحطاتها في القدس
جرى بانه هجوم مركب ومعقد وقال انه يبدو
نتيجه بنيه تحتيه منظمه كما وصف مسؤولون
امنيون وسياسيون اسرائيليون الحادثين
بانهما
خطيرا للغايه
وبعد التفجيرين في القدس باشر رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه يا اير لبيد مشاورات
امنيه عبر الهاتف متابعه للتحقيقات على ان
يعقد جلسات ممثله ظهرا اليوم وقال مكتبه
انبيد سيطلع رئيس الحكومه المكلف
بنيمنتنياهو على صوره الوضع الامني اما
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بنيسان فامر
باغلاق حاجزي الجلمه وسالم العسكريين في
منطقه جنين شمال الضفه الغربيه في ختامين
للوضع الامني
وطالب اثمار بالكثير وهو احد وزعماء
التحالف الصهيونيه الدينيه المتطرف
باجتياح الضفه الغربيه
وتمشيطي وتفتيش كافه منازل الفلسطينيين
فيها جاء تصريحاته بنكفير المرشح الاقوى
لتولي حقيبه الامن الداخلي في حكومه
نتنياهو الجديده لدى وصوله الى موقع احد
تفجيرين الذين وقع في محطتين للحافلات في
القدس الغربيه الصباح اليوم
الارهاب
السياسيون اسرائيليون وصفوا التفجيرين
التفجيرين بالمنعطف الخطير بمطار التصعيد
الذي تشهده المنطقه لان هذا النوع من
الهجمات الفلسطينيه هو الاول من نوعه 2011
السفاره الامريكيه في اسرائيل دانت
التفجيرين في القدس وقالت انها تراقب
الوضع عن كثب من مقابل
الفلسطينيه حيث قال الناطق باسم حركه حماس
عبد اللطيف القنوع تعقيبا على هذه العمليه
ان العمليه تاتي في ايطاليا الرد المستمر
على اقتحام المسجد الاقصى وتهويده وجرائم
الاحتلال والمستوطنين المتواصله بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني قال القيادي وفي حركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه خضر حبيب ان المقاومه مستمره
وان الشعب الفلسطيني مصمم على انتزاع
حقوقي
مهما بلغت التضحيات واشهدت الجبهات
الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين بعمليه القدس وقالت
انها رساله واضحه بان الشعب الفلسطيني لم
يسمح باستمرار ارهاب الجيش الاحتلال
ومستوطنه